vous nous regardez possiblement est ce
matin en train de faire vos toute
dernière boîte avant le grand
déménagement c'est le cas pour des
nombreuses familles au québec des
milliers en fait et depuis des semaines
déjà il ya plusieurs groupes de pression
qui mentionne qu'il ya pénurie de
logements alors il ya des familles qui
ne savent toujours pas où se loger ce
matin alors que c'est le 1er juillet
demain qu'ils devront acquitter
alors pour en parler j'ai joué dans nos
studios à saguenay la ministre les
affaires municipales et de l'habitation
andré la forêt bonjour madame la forêt
bonjour bonjour est ce que vous avez une
idée du nombre de familles qui cherchent
encore un logis aujourd'hui oui on a
pris justement les données hier soir
très tard et présentement si on peut
dire pour la région de montréal il ya
trente trois dossiers qui sont
travaillés présentant que sont
prioritaires nous avions 100 150
dossiers environ nous sommes rendus à 33
dossiers à la ça se passe quand même
très très bien les offices d'habitation
sont toutes sur apple sont sur place
pour les régions justement qu'il y avait
un taux d'occupation de -2% alors puis
les offices d'habitation faut vraiment
de mentionner cette année on les a
vraiment bien restructuré ses différents
alors on est on est prêt à répondre aux
appels
on sent quand même beaucoup d'angoissé
dans les différents témoignages qu'on a
obtenu des gens qui disent avoir fait la
file pour visiter des deux immeubles
pour essayer d'y habiter des gens qui se
font dire non parce qu'ils ont des
enfants
donc comment vous voyez ce que vous
parler aujourd'hui d'une crise du
logement est ce que vous admettez 7
hermelin nom peut pas parler de crise de
logement comme je disais auparavant
d'état points 6% de taux d'inoccupation
n'était quand on est en crise on était
en double on était à ce compromis on est
apprécié présentement on est à 1.9 pour
vraiment respecté ces pourcentages
l'oeil alors évidemment on n'est pas en
pénurie en étant rares thénault effets
sont sur appel
et puis ce que je peux dire c'est que
présentement on donne des psl d'urgence
nos gouvernements très bien réagi tout
près de deux semaines ont dû octroyer 75
psl d'urgence des programmes soutien au
logement qui peut aider justement des
familles à se trouver des logements
abordables
également on
offert le programme aux municipalités
parce que maintenant les affaires
municipales sont avec l'habitation ce
qui est vraiment essentiel
alors on offre aux municipalités la
possibilité de recevoir des subventions
pour aider les gens que je cherche un
logement ou encore pour entreposer leurs
biens dans des entrepôts municipaux
alors on est vraiment vraiment prêt on
est bien structuré on discute toujours
avec le sachent qu on est en
communication hier d'ailleurs j'ai eu
des échanges avec la marisma dame plan
elle également disait qu'on était pas du
pur en pénurie on étend rareté mais tout
le monde travaille à pied d'oeuvre et
puis si je peux dire il ya même des gens
à montréal avec la société d'avec le
fils d'habitation qui ont des camions
prêt si on a des appels
on va les aider les gens déménagent et
alors je peux dire qu'on a pris vraiment
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour bien
vivre ce déménagement du 1er juillet peu
importe le mot comprends qu'on parle de
crise de rareté le résultat est le même
pour les gens qui ont très peur demain
de se retrouver sans logement à quel
point vous êtes sensible à leur
situation
écoutez on est très très sensible parce
que si on a mis en place le programme de
2005 et si on a donné des psl d'urgence
des croyances ou suppléments au loyer
c'est parce que notre gouvernement était
vraiment sensible à la situation on est
vraiment proactif et ceci étant dis moi
ce que je peux dire c'est que les
offices d'habitation ont recensé tous
les logements disponibles tous les
logements louit depuis le mois de mai à
la réunion la liste des logements
disponibles c'est certain qu'il ya des
gens qui se prennent toujours à la
dernière minute on vit ça encore en fin
de semaine sauf que nous on est prêt les
offices on les appelle sont disponibles
ligne téléphonique fonctionne autant à
gatineau à sherbrooke à montréal parce
que c'est les 300 endroits que le taux
d'inoccupation est le plus bas alors on
est prêt puis il n'y a pas de problème
on va réagir on va trouver des logements
puis on a même les municipalités qui
peuvent accompagner les locataires dans
le besoin il ya des problèmes qu'on
entend beaucoup à ces données à ces
derniers jours madame la forêt à ya
celui de la pénurie de logements celui
donc que les gens n'en trouve pas mais
également celui de la surenchère
les gens qui paient beaucoup plus cher
par rapport à leurs moyens pour pouvoir
se loger
est ce que vous pensez à des solutions
registre de hbos par exemple ou des lois
plus sévères par rapport aux
propriétaires écoutez au niveau de la
fixation des loyers on a pris en charge
justement sur ces dossiers là on regarde
et demain au regarde comment on peut
fonctionner c'est certain que moi je dis
toujours aux propriétaires de faire
attention parce qu'il faut quand même
accepter des gens qui sont en capacité
de payer le montant qui est demandé et
en même temps faut vous faut faire des
enquêtes de crédit sur les futurs
locataires le cloud et des logements aux
propriétaires mais ceci étant dit oui
j'ai je prends notre très bien là c'est
la cage g du bail de la régie du
logement alors oui la fixation des taux
de loyer et étudier chez nous avec la
société d'habitation
vous comprendrez qu'il ya eu une année
qu auriez fait en habitation de par les
années passées mais ce que je peux dire
c'est que cette année on a commencé tout
de suite à revoir justement avec la
régie du logement
on a d'ailleurs le projet de loi 16 qui
donne des mesures plus incitatives et
plus plus est dans ce que je peux dire
avec la régie du logement dans le projet
de loi 16 alors toutes les mesures au
niveau de l'habitation sont prises sont
prises en considération puis on
travaille toujours de l'avant il ya
également 260 millions qui a été octroyé
par notre gouvernement pour offrir des
accès logis pour construire des accès
logis des nouveaux logements abordables
au québec alors c'est vraiment important
de le mentionner avec mon collègue érige
eric girard aux finances alors
maintenant on va pouvoir donner plus de
logements abordables on a aussi la liste
des coûts de construction admissibles
parce qu'on a aussi de 25% ce qui veut
dire que les promoteurs vont être en
mesure de bien construire des immeubles
à logements alors on a vraiment pris les
mesures qu'on devait prendre on est
responsable on discute toujours avec
toutes les offices et je pointe claire
du tout du tout cas on va bien passer ce
1er juillet à loos en problème est ce
que vous vous assurez en terminant à
madame la ministre que il ya personne
qui sera laissée demain la haye sans
logement il y aura une solution qui sera
trouvée pour tout le monde
je voudrais je vous rassure vraiment que
je dis justement toutes les
municipalités que elles peuvent aider
les gens qui n'ont pas de logement il ya
le système conomie le programme de 2005
qu'on a remis en place et les
municipalités peuvent loger les gens
temporairement ceci dit pendant trois
mois d'inattendu et on va leur trouver
un logement sans problème puis je
remercie également le frapru parce que
il ya quelques jours il ya deux jours
auparavant nous ont remerciés pour
toutes les mesures que le ministère
d'habitation des affaires municipales on
avait mis en place alors on est remercié
également du frapru cet organisme qui
servait également toute la rareté de
logements dans les grandes régions comme
montréal à la si tout le monde est
d'accord qu'on a fait les bonnes les
bonnes démarches qu on a pris nos
responsabilités
alors je vois pas pourquoi qu'on aurait
une une difficulté à passer à ce 1er
juillet la nuit on nous sommes prêts ça
va très bien on va faire le point
d'ailleurs avec les gens du frapru et de
la corpiq demain 1er juillet a donc le
jour même de ce festival du déménagement
au québec entre la forêt ministre des
affaires municipales et de l'habitation
merci merci à vous au revoir